[Music]
I'm gonna jump ridiculously and I'm
gonna bash my teeth into the microphone
or something like that that was just so
great because it was so you gonna
watch the tape it's so perfect trying to
do a show from the outside and they may
be far too little I hate it so you drew
blood
that's basically you're drawing blood
and that's situation we'll see there's I
mean if I can get him to piss his pants
I don't know if I don't think I yeah
it's so funny because I never thought as
two friends that you two would be the
ones that would match bully and ultimate
thing bully wants which is there's a
shot I'm telling you there's a shot if I
feel right now that a drip of piss came
out of my pee hole when he tickled me
it's possible I feel like it's possible
you check I mean are you that big of a
quick draw what how many how many
coochie-coochie-coo is would it take you
to piss now no Dan never tested
the amount of coochie coos can we do it
I'm a seven coochie-coo
I mean then you gonna know like it's
like licks of a Tootsie Pop
exactly you'll be like he's got two more
and I'm gonna blow I don't even
know it was so much looking over so much
like the reaction of tickle like the
laughing I think it's like the not being
able to stop someone prodding me yeah
yeah dude I if someone touches my
ribcage I'll because I'm blonde
Shana hasn't tickled me yet but he's got
me on the things you're like oh I
it but I hate it I hate it so
we'll see where tickle gets bad is where
you
get up under the armpits in your
just I'll never think anybody in the you
ever try that when there's locked in
they know whatever tickled in UFC they
should have they showed up they
definitely shows it on a band move to
start tickling someone just getting the
beat out of you and you just get
one thing if you go for the tickle and
that person will not ticklish you are
gonna get nervous that was a bad move on
Bors in or he gets tickled and pees and
then furiously beats the show that's my
fear with you if I get him if I'd make
him piss he's gonna attack it's gonna be
like like the kid in school where I'm
gonna have pants full of piss and I'm
gonna be on top of you hitting and
crying at this it's like that old
Colorado proverb make a bear piss and
I'll eat your goddamn face I think I
think you'd straight go straight grizzly
on them
I think you'd be right shame doc hell
yeah why the Jamesburg I would still win
the war just keep saying you're not
gonna do it anymore then you turn right
around again welcome back to cereal in
1995 I didn't sit like this jazz my feet
up in shame I don't want to sit next to
Dan okay words I'm have to pull you out
of the pit dog what about the burritos
yeah I'm out to put you every night you
know what if you're good and you make me
laugh a bunch
why don't you come over here every KJ to
be comfortable
Jacob snap Jacob's happier you're closer
what subjects we talking about now I'm
loose moon towers gonna be a blast
I'm a punk man can't wait if I
see black lo and Dan looking a little
bit down it's probably NBA 2k stuff lost
its aura we'll just talk about it when
we get back next we're gonna have to but
I have to mend friendships I don't even
think I did this is the bonfire Commerce
central radio sirius XM 295 I'm Dan
Soder that's big Jay oakerson Shane
Gillis sitting in with us from Matt and
Shane's secret podcast yes suck our dick
tall for enemy all of our enemies can
eat dick he's there he's gonna
tickle your dicks off I want to take my
pee that's not gay see almost the gays
thing if I just giggle that I can tell
you if you are on I giggle insane it's
live footage these little tickly boys
vana tickly boy there's such a tickly
boy you're not even getting touched yeah
yeah everyone smile give him a hug or
something or like grab him I can tell
how much he hate your hugger
yeah Oh what am I on my other people oh
oh he's gotta go he's gonna reach out
you go high on me I'll get under you
drive you into the wall under hooks
anybody who are pinned against that
fence yeah I've been there what if
that's what I want your bark up the
right tree yeah you wanna
come get some of this nurse shark
barking up the right tree
oh we rub it sticks what's happening
what's going on Dan Soder I found the
position in life where you are going
find the woman of your dreams lady one
figured it out here me and Christine
went and we'll talk about that in a
second - the Sixers game last night
interesting game three four five seventy
six yeah when we first got there loving
that shot when we first got there we hit
up Matt cord the in-house announcer has
come down and watch the warm-up but JJ
Redick stood for about ten minutes doing
dribbling drills with two balls yeah and
Christine was just panties soaked she
had to almost tell she had to almost
tell Matt cord that her panties were
soaked she was mad I gotta stop and she
told me it was the sexiest hottest thing
she's ever seen and then we told Matt
cord she goes that's the coolest thing
I've ever seen like is it cool cool you
didn't tell me cool it is cool they were
drums it was crazy he's super hot doing
it Redick is a babe I shook hands I went
home and jerked off oh it's slap
Christine across the face with a hand
sorry it's already been washed off with
free Neutrogena look look come to get
your girl jail bring up a video him
double ball dribbling and see if find it
see if Becky gets moist little ass is so
wet waiting for you casting powder you
gonna bring this go way back to
your house guys got religious tattoos
all over his arm and you gonna
bring him home for bring them on the
Sukkot a weird one yeah that's a good
one is that the one six or you would
this is what Haman this is what
Haman would want would you want to be
drinking my Jewish friends left this is
exactly what he wants these assholes eat
hamantaschen don't even know the story
you know I don't like it hey Shane I'm
you see guys hold on I'm trying to cut
everything down shame you know you know
who just rose be cool dude
Jesus rose after your people tried to
it hold him back he's Jewish
he busted out of there so these Jews
can't stop me dude let's roll
for Jesus Jewish Jesus was doing beated
Jews lift the tables and that's how he
became on Josh what have you found out
that was in the Bible or said let's roll
let's roll dude break I'm done
with this the Jews keep your focus let's
roll
yo Matt Matthew 1527 says and the lamb
said let's rolling so everyone
that doesn't know we do a Lost Tapes
that's coming out where Jay basically
says his talent and 2k surpasses any of
ours so much so that he toys with us
just to make it entertaining and to save
the friendship so Shane after a fair one
tonight he's gonna go over to big J's to
play a game of 2k because Shane link
down the Thunder you still believe that
you're better than him at 2k I think
he's bluffing dude yeah I do this this
will be fun I thought before the game
even starts I'm gonna go whisper in the
christine's here and have her write down
how the game's gonna go okay the
trajectory of the game and then when the
game's over she'll come out and she's
not gonna watch I would I set myself up
to fail like that okay no I'm not gonna
let you totally embarrass me just go in
and play a game dude play a game quit
shobhona win for all the troops honestly
as your friend and as your radio partner
I wouldn't take these troops our Jesus I
would probably say I would go with the
referee the Father don't refugees should
I try Heyman again guys don't even know
Heyman is guys you want to be a jail but
it's Dan what's up sure listen man I'm
just helping you with your public image
I understand you're getting a little on
your heels you know
with the Google Translate a Hebrew is
the book of Esther you guys have your
hand of the Lord and I can bust out on
our Father
this isn't funny
this isn't funny to joke about the
Lord's Prayer stop at your Armenian oh
yeah I just watched a movie about you
guys you guys have rough go do the Turks
didn't enjoy it nobody wants to
women we have to shave their feet
I mean uh Christine Christine gonna
shave your feet just my toes right out
of you oh my god can we let it go so she
could be a hill person I think that
genocide grew that will you stay
together behind the scenes but I publish
proto both you guys got genocided yeah
guard do because good news is J what she
can hang on for so he's got to go back
to Mordor some point yes if she destroys
that she destroys that ring I hope well
Christine we're gonna have to talk about
this back of the Shire it's gonna be
weird showing that hairy feet how bad
like hair on my hand like I would shave
my hands when I was like seven but now
Christine shut the up so gross J Oh
shades her hands like Wolverine she's
like I give it a week
yellow milk out of my nipples I've never
been pregnant she was I can pretty much
hang from anything set of hands three
days Christine how do you wear
flip-flops so much if you have a hairy
feet suits finger I don't ever let
anyone see that I'd have a full-blown
mustache if I didn't take care of it we
let it go we just so I mean I might have
to because I'm getting laser can we get
a P I know let it grow in if you're
getting away I don't think so I think if
you do I swear to god you have to move
out for a little bit I
shame promise you'll never see me with a
mustache why I'm not gonna rope away
yeah perfect perfect disguise everything
any day if I have a hair real rough it
was sick I had a mustache for a sec yeah
why don't you try beard and everybody
was hyped on it it just comes in
scraggly yeah yeah no beard
I couldn't picture a life of shaving my
face every day ever since I've had
facial hair she have it every couple
days but every since I've had facial
hair I've had facial hair ever since I
was able to grow it yeah in some
capacity it was like in the beginning
great for have seen eyes it was
yeah it was shitty goatee yeah I just
let my fat face hang out all the time
why it won't grow dear you don't work
you don't get family or nothing
let me see almost nothing how often do
you shave you look so imagine that with
the beard dude they might not want to
show this isn't there some porno I'm
pretending and it's so hard how often
you have to shave well if I let it go it
just looks horrible so like every twice
a week maybe once a week but have you
ever let it go past horrible to see how
yeah let it go because the thing is I
grew a mustache
if I shave my face bald if I shave my
face bald which I won't but it did no
way but if I did that would be a bet I
bet I'd shave my facial hair off tonight
I beat you guys but I wouldn't do it for
20 points I'd say I beat you for sure
okay I won beats me definitely a deal my
mustache out see how
passive-aggressive was that you feel it
there which I do for you I love the
beard though so don't
his hair and I love this short hair so I
think I'm putting the beard on the line
again Shane tonight an NBA 2k holy
they're very exciting well why can't
that mean why are you afraid what do you
think put the beard on put that beer
down the line the people want the people
I guarantee the people listening right
now are screaming yes put the beard on
line you said you could control us like
kittens Shane and I kittens can I do it
was he kidding can I shut up Stan that
does feel good put her hey
sasquatch hey Topher Oh do me a favor
I'll fight my own battles line 10 on the
line the beard games Shane and Jay on
the beard game I'll get the terms dude
set the difficulty to pro computer can't
play defense for you the whole
time what set to set the difficulty to
Pro all that means is just easier to hit
shots yes and the computer is easier to
beat I got to beat the computer to be
you don't play defense you're defending
him because you do the same
thing
don't you I play defense play off the
ball by the way it's not
fully true because I try to steal the
inbound when I play your guy up but then
I know how to switch because I'm playing
the passing lanes what's wrong with that
I say it's real Heyman right now
difficulties Pro why a difficulty
definitely on Pro which is boring yeah
you gotta go all-star
you guys go all-star at least I'll do
all-star if we risk the Fiat yeah put
the beard on the line get it out there
because then if you beat Shane he has to
grow facial hair for four weeks Oh che
vuoi no Shane that's a terrible bet for
me because I'm probably gonna lose
there's a spread then if we're doing
that no no she's gonna shave his beard
dude he's going to the festival holy
I have to do damage control all
weekend with Jamie like you look fine I
don't want to do a show I'm gonna wear a
fake beard I'm gonna get spirit gum and
Christine's gonna beard me every day
before I go out
Team America yeah so you'd have to grow
up for weeks yeah that's a rough
one dude I look so bad I know oh look if
I shave my beard I got a fat child's old
face that's right dude I'm so
win it
this is gotta have I don't have your
sureness oh yes oh we're a fake
beard you could join Isis cover that
thing up we gon' you to TV with a low
beard once I'm trying to find a shot put
it on the line you said you toyed with
us you said you you say you were writing
down how the games gonna go and
Christine I bet I'll let Christine's bat
feet know shave the beard and by the way
you you caught Shane slippin you missed
him slipping he said he was gonna shave
his eyebrows see I mean for weeks our
growing facial hair sporadic and ratty I
grow hair like a like an Asian
philosopher he just doles out wisdom
don't start doling out wisdom just crazy
good wisdom with teams were using here
first western all-stars among much
let me as the Commissioner I'm gonna
pull that if this is a beard game so
it's three random three random fourth is
it fourth you have to hold ya before if
you have to use if you go yeah three
orders five minute quarters no we do six
minute quarters over thumbs down to keep
it closed five minute quarters just with
the standard is six your stand goes
quick fine
six minutes is beard game beard game six
minutes Dan's gonna be there ref and
I'll be there either way Dan wins cuz
one of us is a win-win for the old
bighead don't be upset about the game we
play but then he's gonna beat me in
round ball classic what about you are
you getting in anything I can't be and
Dan out of money better way Victor Dan
up to shave his head if he lose I
got that big dome out there see if I had
my senior high school the biggest regret
I've ever had was buzzing my head I do
not have a head to be I did it once
never again yeah my dad no but Jacob
would look really good with his shave
that he's just the guy cuts my hair
because I went in the last time I said
I'm thinking to shave my head people
said it looked good with it and he
pulled my hair back he said this is how
you're gonna look and I was horrified
not BIC not BIC razors went like that
and he just showed it look I'm not gonna
do it Cory's got the camera trained on
the top of my head right I see Shane
thinking right now I can't go I can't
grow my facial hair out because May 11th
I'll be at helium comedy club I agreed I
can't have that you know single with a
bald face I won't do it okay yeah dude
no way you don't get out of this because
the heels i sandwich she doesn't
wanna he doesn't want to do it no I
definitely will do it no you won't do it
yeah
why are you trying to back out no you
said also I get to tickle you I want to
shave your face and tickle you piss all
over myself
Oh No thank you Shane I'm commissioning
this fight I'm telling you right now the
beard game is happening it's four weeks
versus J shaving his face clean bit I
mean to the razor shave to the face
bald no yeah leave anything at the
bonfire sxm on Instagram we will insert
a story this right Christine you'll be
there and so we'll let you guys know
probably your progress it's probably
gonna be around as gonna be so
embarrassing I want to say the game's
gonna start around 9:45 p.m. Eastern
like just IG live live on Instagram yeah
let's go IG live I'll show you guys the
game oh we do that yeah also I also
wanted clear that I'm definitely going
to lose this but the risk and reward on
this is I know great rule if I could
make Jay have to shave his beard I think
you already got a wobble to because you
think I care if I look ugly I really
feel bad this is my life
come on relying on looks to get anywhere
exchange new theme song should be
atmospheres God loves ugly four weeks is
gonna be rough though dude my bummer
because you know what that is right hate
I hate to bring out the fans all sitting
and watching a game that I'm gonna
nervously open this game up with a big
lead and never lose it I don't want to
lose that means you have to go to May
22nd wow I sound up forever yeah May
22nd is four weeks from now the good
news is my beard will be back in about a
week and a half should be roughly know
how nice it is right now it looks nice
manicured I know it's manicured it's got
the two but the 20 bucks get this done
it's gonna hurt that to shave I'm
Jesus dude Bobby beat this
doing
don't use what they did to you Jesus I'm
so upset I don't know if I could do it
the reveal of the three - of the two
teams is gonna be so intense you may
like draft day you pick the fourth team
and you get with the Cavs or something
oh man and I'll just be there doing
color commentary no Sixers no sisters
Sixers aren't allowed that's it
Warriors are allowed you can't random
the same team twice everything yeah
we're ready yeah it's all locked in we
got a locked-in deal we have it on
videotape we have it on the radio
address is he does coke off his daughter
he likes me to eat tickles until he
pisses why you are though
[Music]
Shane trying to tickle me I'll come to
turn yeah thanks dude is if you don't
call me out or also I swear to God
you call me all these people walking by
I will remove myself and I'll put I'll
put shame the tickle on Shane and tickle
monster killer Dan Soder American Hero
I pee if I get tickled hard I hate it
don't tell people
chains gunning for it and I'm acting
that's the buffer and I'm pretty excited
about this yeah Oklahoma Oklahoma tree
stop bro that's cool you cool just
making sure you're cool cool I just keep
a distance the vet at the stand or dig a
mile she's coming yeah wrist control why
are you getting so close what are you a
plan I'm saving your ass
thank you you'll need a sickle me I'll
tell you what I'm doing I'm here to save
the day thanks bro Shane goes
from man change secret teens podcast see
her teens
tttt dude Shanga hammer on scones was so
fun I believe you right
that's a card I really have to go
it's Bev there she's there
windows wins Aryan blood let's are
always know I like I 10 so so much my
pants no I got so small I made myself
tiny trying to lure her in Becky's been
my friend longer of hating being tickled
of worrying about Cosley being tickled
we are sure though we gotta do a show we
gotta do a show
listen I could separate myself and you
can attack them hey why though
see that's why I don't go about our
friendship though so for remember from
before I love you let's see what see how
much more control drug in it now watch
out
Jayla get you a tickle vest I bet tell
me all about it she have a hot ass is
right yeah
flak jacket yeah my way I'm such a piece
of I stopped to look too I'm going
through a gauntlet of chairs
stay away yeah really
what's that
God dude hop in oh that door opens cool
agency no it opens what I farted a
little come on in if you dare you me
fart a little dude porno Bowie that's
gonna be your album title gotta pee my
question is how fast did the fart come
from the tickle so quick because
everything is it's a shame no of course
we have my arm locked I'm sorry tickling
like this and yeah a little to get you
the showers did you trust the classic
dusky mentor job you say you're gonna
mentor me he taught you proper tackling
for bye guys like why don't you guys go
until 6:15 like a chain it's crazy it's
crazy it's going over there
what a funny weakness hey you should
leave a comment below one of us might be
in a depression spiral and read it yeah
I just push us all the way down yeah
yeah may I can get pretty dark it's
weird so look forward to reading it